Edward hopper is a special artist for a
lot of us.
I've always thought of him in a sort of
romantic way because his paintings evoke
the same kind of feelings and memories
in me that I get from the sense of smell
is if he was channeling directly into my
limbic system,
excavating moments that were stored
deeply away,
a stubborn realist throughout the mini
changing and often abstract currents of
modern art in the early and mid 20th
century.
His canvases are clean,
smooth,
and almost too real,
not real like his contemporary Andrew
Wyeth,
for example,
who strive for detail and photo realism,
but pulled back by one degree into
depictions,
slightly more generalized,
slightly more detached from place
history and person in this way.
There's just enough room to put your own
life into hopper's work,
but once inside,
it's impossible not to be closed in and
see that life along his themes.
Nearly all those themes are present in
nighthawks.
Unquestionably the artists,
most famous work themes of loneliness,
alienation,
voyeurism,
quiet contemplation,
and more.
The scene depicts for people in New York
City diner at night.
It's meant to be somewhere in Greenwich
village where hopper lived,
but decades of exhaustive searching have
concluded that it was never a real
place.
There was one waiter and three patrons
who is relationships are all ambiguous,
seated so close together in an empty
diner at night.
It's likely that these two know each
other somehow,
but though their hands overlap,
they don't touch and they're in
different phases suggest that they could
be strangers if not just momentarily
estranged.
The main character of the piece seems to
be the diner itself and island of light
in the outer darkness.
It's diagonal lines are strong
accentuated by the counter and the
stools and we're seeing the diner at an
odd angle as if from the vantage of
someone crossing the street,
it's triangular corner juts into the
frame like the prow of a boat,
and this is no coincidence.
Not only was hopper obsessed with the
imagery of boats,
but he repeatedly situated his buildings
at angles like this and the point of
that I think was to achieve and effect
in which his subjects were both behind
and in front of windows.
Of course,
windows are the place where the
separation between outside and inside
becomes complicated and not because we
can physically move through them,
but because our site does,
because our gaze invades these private
worlds.
Indeed in hopper's work,
the windows often appear as if they're
not even there as opposed to someone
like Norman Rockwell who had a talent
for giving glass,
a texture hoppers windows vanish.
They invite that voyeuristic look,
knowing that houses like people can be
penetrated with a gaze.
Copper was a very slow,
very deliberate painter.
He took months to finish a canvas and
made several sketches and studies before
embarking on the final piece in these
sketches for Nighthawks,
we can see hopper out on the street
looking for the right back angle for
this man modifying to find the perfect
effect.
Here's his sketches of Josephine,
his wife,
who modeled for the woman in the
painting.
Here's her right hand holding a
cigarette,
which he eventually transplanted to her
partner hopper,
wanted his devotion to each work to be
mirrored by our appreciation as slowly
and deliberately as he painted.
He wanted us to look really look to be
made vulnerable as a viewer,
always is whether he or she is crouching
in the dark and the building opposite or
simply crossing the street.
There's no door to the diner and
nighthawks,
no way in except by way of site.
That site enters the fluorescent light
of the establishment,
passes through the three patrons in
there on wheat and loneliness and exits
into the dark for bidding night behind
them.
You know I,
I wonder about that.
Darkness hopper tried very hard to on
more his work from the historical
moment.
You didn't want only to be judged in the
context of his time and place,
but it's worth noting that this painting
was completed in the weeks and days
following the bombing of Pearl Harbor
when everyone in New York City was
paranoid about another attack,
the city held blackout drills a way to
practice hiding the city in darkness.
If an aerial assault ever came,
but hopper didn't care,
his studio lights stayed on.
As his wife wrote in her diary,
ed refuses to take any interest in the
very likely prospect of being bombed.
This was the atmosphere in which night
hawks was Ford.
Did it have an influence on the
painting?
I don't know.
The future was very uncertain at this
moment in time,
as uncertain as the darkness that frames
the patrons of the Steiner,
a darkness there launched into by
hoppers composition and our gaze.
The artist was obsessed with light,
how it fell on houses,
on people through windows.
The colors that made hopper seemed to
disregard the chaos in the world around
him,
but is it a coincidence that like his
studio,
the light of the nighthawk,
Steiner seems to be the last light still
shining in the city,
and for this reason,
I think you can find a slightly more
optimistic reading of this painting.
What is there to do in the face of great
disquiet and doubt,
but work and live on all the poppers.
People seem to be huddled up against the
present moment.
Lonely.
Yes.
Waiting maybe a little board people have
nighthawks are no different,
but boredom is exactly when we feel time
and being the most acutely.
It can inspire a profound mood.
Maybe that's what these people are
feeling alone together in their lighted
ship,
sailing against the darkness of all that
was yet to come.
The yellowish greenish fluorescent light
in this scene like the light and hopper
studio is a meager substitute for the
brilliance of the sun,
but it can through giant windows still
illuminated the world.
Hey everybody.
Thanks for watching.
Nighthawks is one of my favorite
paintings ever.
So that was just a lot of fun to make.
So two big announcements.
One,
we are about to hit 100,000
subscribers on the nerd writer channel.
It might be at 100,000
by the time this video goes out.
Ah,
that's amazing.
I've been doing this for over four years
and it's been amazing and fun and
exciting and fascinating from the very
start.
So thank you to everyone who's been with
me from the beginning,
who's come on recently and everything in
between.
Um,
the nerdwriter is,
it's,
you know,
it's my profession,
that's my career and it's everything
that I want to do.
So there's gonna be a lot more of it.
The other big news is that we crossed
the thousand dollars on the Patriot on
this week,
uh,
and I just have to thank you so much for
that.
Um,
you know,
we're right at the beginning now of
what's making this financially feasible
for me.
So thank you for pledging on patron to
the nerd writer if you haven't already,
I'd love for you to pledge to this
project,
um,
and help me keep making these videos
because there is so much more stuff that
I want to do more painting analysis and
film analysis and understanding art.
But a lot of other cool stuff too.
Um,
that will be coming your way soon.
So thank you again and I will see you
guys next Wednesday.